from the 48 levels of power law 21 play
a sucker to catch a sucker seem dumber
than your mark
so when i was preparing for this
i was reading these daily
um
these daily meditations and i was
actually shocked i was really quite
shocked by them i was shocked by that
one and i was very unclear as a
consequence
as to your motivations and so i was
thinking do i want to do i want to i
don't get this i don't understand this
exactly it's like this is very deceptive
and then i talked to my team
who like your books a lot and and my
daughter who really liked interviewing
you and i thought well there's something
going on here that i don't quite
understand which is certainly possible
and then i thought well
this is maybe a shadow exploration
something like that yes and then i
thought like i was kind of a dimwit for
not catching that earlier but so but you
know it is shocking these are very
manipulative uh laws let's say and so
can you guide me through
the rationale for producing material
like that
what were you trying what are you trying
to do with your books and they've
obviously been misunderstood it says in
the in wikipedia green's books are
sometimes described as manipulative and
amoral and so clear this up for me well
you know that it's a it's a bit
manipulative when people write that
because a great deal of the 48 laws of
power i'd say you know maybe two-thirds
of them are not manipulative have
nothing to do with deception they have
things to do with kind of common sense
ideas about power such as such as being
generous with people such as creating
compelling spectacles
such as entering action with boldness
and kind of how you present yourself
sort of things about your image and your
appearance but there are definitely some
laws that are quite manipulative and
then my other books don't really go into
things like that so it is a bit of a
distortion to write that but where this
comes from
is basically um i have a particular idea
of power so maybe i should explain that
a little bit my idea of power it's not
about this kind of grand thing of
political or war something it's on a
very individual level
and the idea for me comes from from
nietzsche and his idea of the will to
power which he explains as all every
organism has the desire to expand itself
as a desire for expansion and so i think
that for human beings the desire that we
we have this innate
propensity for wanting to expand beyond
our limits we want to feel
like we have some degree
of ability to influence other people
that we can control our own career and
learn more and develop greater skills
and have more kind of power and
influence in our life the feeling that i
cannot have any power or influence over
my children my spouse my colleagues my
boss
my career in general is deeply deeply
unsettling for the human animal and
causes all kinds of attempts at what i
call negative power passive aggression
etc
setting yourself up as a victim's kind
of leverage power in a negative way and
so the problem is
um and i this a lot of this comes from
machiavelli who inspired a lot of the 48
laws
the problem is that we live in a world
where this desire for some kind of power
butts up against
kind of codes of behavior that have
gotten stricter and stricter and
stricter in particular in the 21st
century
about what is acceptable about what is
politically correct
so we're supposed to appear to be these
paragons of virtue these paragraphs of
fairness and democracy etc at the same
time we're all trying to angle for
different degrees of power in our work
in our relationships etc and so
because of that dynamic we have to be
extremely careful in this world and i
compare it to the courts
of like louis xiv
where all of the courtiers if they're
too overt in their power moves the king
will disapprove of them and will not
banish them but they'll be kind of
excluded to the corner of the palace and
so the game was to be sort of indirect
to be polite and ingratiating and if you
had an enemy to know how to kind of very
quietly get rid of them
and so
this is kind of
what i would the what kid where the 48
laws of power came out from so you
quoted me i had like 80 different jobs
probably more like 60 65
but i saw all kinds of very
deceptive games being played continually
in the various different jobs i had and
i i worked in every conceivable field
and
i didn't see any kind of honesty about
this dynamic in the human world and it
really kind of irritated me all the
self-help books were sort of
describing a world that i never saw
existed
you know i saw people being very
political having egos and having
problems with their egos
and i didn't see anybody any books like
they're kind of describing what i
encountered every day
so law number one is never outshine the
master
and the idea is that if you try too hard
to impress your boss or the person above
you you're liable to make them feel
insecure you're going to trip on their
ego and something bad will happen to you
right and so this seemed like
the fact that people have egos and
operate with egos and you have to be
careful with them seems very clear to me
but i didn't find books out there that
were describing it
so i hope this kind of gives you an idea
a little bit of the context where the
book came out okay yeah well the okay so
i just
i can't remember who sent me this
i think it was clay routledge yeah i
think that's right
he just sent me a survey that this
organization he works with has
completed
stating that something like 40 percent
of millennials don't feel they have any
control over their life right so that is
related to the first issue that you
brought up and
and
you you obviously consider that uh
problematic and you said that well we
need to
it's good for us to have some control
over our destinies and also to feel that
that's a possibility to see it at least
as a goal yes and then and that if
if we
feel consciously
thwarted in that goal or believe that
it's impossible that doesn't mean we're
going to give up our striving it means
it's going to go underground and then
it's going to manifest itself in all
sorts of deceptive ways exactly and then
you you said that
you were interested in nietzsche's idea
of will to power as in some sense the
central motivating
uh the central motivation of of the
organism yeah across species to some
degree
um
and and then you talked about the jobs
that you've had so why why did so i got
that right i hope i i hope i've got this
dude that was very well thank you okay
okay and so
and so to some degree and then you said
well you had all these jobs and you
found that people were engaged in
manipulative and deceptive strategies a
fair number of
a fair amount of the time and that no
one was really warning people about this
or delineating out the strategies yeah
okay so that you know that seems to me
to be reasonable that
i mean i'm a big admirer of the work of
carl jung which everyone listening to
this knows more than they even want to
know um and he was certainly
sensitive
to the idea that people had a terrible
shadow yes that
they would clothe themselves in the
garments of moral virtue right and act
out a virtuous persona but because of
the thwarted will to strive in some
sense that
they have all sorts of motivations
sexual power related dominance
um aggression anger resentment that
aren't admitted thoroughly and that are
snakes under the carpet or elephants
under the rug or skeletons in the closet
and they pollute human relationships and
i certainly believe that's true i
believe that that that's
the corruption of human relationships by
a form of of severe deceit and i also
think it's reasonable to warn people
against that and also to alert them to
the fact that such things operate in
their own souls